hi I'm Eric Voss and brick at Ralph -
Ralph breaks the internet contained more
hidden details and I think we'll ever be
able to find I wouldn't be surprised if
I'm in there somewhere
I am Internet and I am broken let Surrey
watch this movie see my scene to see all
the subtle Easter eggs that you might
have missed I mean at least as many as
we could find more other morning if I
haven't seen the movie yet and let's get
started ok this sequel opens back at lip
wax arcade and right away one detail
tells us exactly six years have passed
since the first movie notice the arcade
sign it says happy 11th birthday Susie
that's a callback to the first record
Ralph when it said happy 5th birthday
Susie Susie what the vide must strap a
lot of quarters here if you look behind
this arcade there's a few other Easter
eggs there's a billboard for locked it's
diner that's a reference for this movies
production designer Cory Loftus inside
game Central Station Ralph and vanellope
voiced by john c reilly and sarah
silverman play among a lot of the
familiar game characters in the last
movie there's pac-man the ghost Sonic
the Hedgehog Robotnik all the old
familiar faces are coming back and after
Ralph accidentally wrecks sugar rush
Felix and Calhoun adopt the homeless
sugar rush racers leading Felix to share
a root beer with Ralph at tapper OS by
Jack McBrayer Felix's near break down at
the bar echos McBrayer newlywed
character in the movie forgetting sarah
marshall as Ralph and vanellope sneak
into the Wi-Fi router we see lit wax
office with a few more fun details on
the shelf behind him our collectable
Star Wars plates showing Yoda and
Chewbacca and on his Mac desktop when
the file says letter to Nana that's kind
of a callback to the first movie when
Litwack mentioned how his Nana had just
gone cuckoo okay then Ralph and
vanellope blast into the Internet which
the animators filled with logos of
pretty much every website and web
company that you can think of Google
Amazon YouTube there's an Instagram
museum Hulu I'm to be snapchat logos for
Reddit and Facebook up here we see birds
tweeting tweets at each other and the
Twitter tree Wikipedia shows up on a
pedestal Pinterest shows up in the end
of the movie Ralph's actually uses the
big pin to fight the virus copies and of
course eBay a few pop-up ads show up at
the entrance of ebay one mentioned sassy
housewives want to meet you and the
woman that photo is actually aunt Cass
from the movie big hero 6 there's
another Papa bad that's
Elson Anna's father from frozen King
ignore the pop-up salesman that they
later follow is JP's family and he's
voiced by Bill Hader meanwhile the
search bar character knows more is
voiced by alan tudyk who actually voiced
King candy slash turbo in the first
movie some of the items up for auction
at eBay include a few other Disney
references there's the frying pan of
Rapunzel and tangled and the genie lamp
from Aladdin
for 35 bucks but I guess it could be a
joke about how the lamp is considered
worthless at the beginning in the movie
raus tantrum at not having actual money
to buy the steering wheel leads to one
Avatar woman getting smashed causing her
real-world counterpart to lose her
internet service this is actually a
cameo about youtuber Miranda sings and a
few other famous youtubers actually make
cameos throughout this movie including
Danny Fernandez Tiffany Herrera and
Flula Borg
if you look around spam Lee's shady
office it looks like there's a few
gaming details tucked around there
there's a few question boxes from the
Mario games and this mounted unicorn
head that made me think it could be the
one from Robot Unicorn Attack and the
game that he gives them leads them to
slaughter race a game that appears to be
some kind of mix of Grand Theft Auto and
maybe the twisted metal games they're
trying to steal shanks car now shank is
voiced by one woman herself gal gadot
who appears to be inspired by Giselle
from The Fast and Furious movies though
in the story she's like the team leader
the way Dom Toretto is in this game a
huge shark burst out of the sewer to eat
a scary dog just like how seminal
Jackson's character died in deep blue
sea actually later during the song we
see that this shark has a Louisiana
license plate in its mouth it's a same
kind of license plate that turned up
inside the tiger shark in Jaws during
this chase vanellope drifts past a clown
liquor store sign which is actually a
recreation of a real-life liquor store
in North Hollywood it showed up in a
bunch of movies like clueless now shank
directs them to buzz tube and this whole
part of the movie I really enjoy it
because it really nails what it feels
like to be a youtuber everything from
playing algorithms to getting really
depressed by you're eating comments
Ralph's experience as a youtuber
features references to lots of trending
ideas Chewbacca mom flossing screaming
goats spa bras eating ghost peppers
unboxing videos at one point there's a
viral video of a cat shoving the doll
off a table if you look closely it's
actually a doll of Anna from frozen and
while trying to help promote rouse
videos Penelope ventures into oh my
Disney which oma contains the highest
concentration of digital rip
is in the movie maybe any movie ever so
the exterior design is of course
Cinderella's castle the same one from
the Disney title card and I like how
it's surrounded by a bunch of hotels
just like the Disney theme parks are and
if you listen closely you can hear a
cover of let it go from frozen
now inside there are things from all of
Disney's major brands from Marvel
there's Ironman he blasts paths
vanellope flies over to a big Iron Man
repulsor gauntlet along with cap shield
and Thor's hammer in a Star Wars section
you can see r2d2 an x-wing TIE fighter a
Death Star Millennium Falcon and beside
it is a big muppet section with a Kermit
head can actually see Baker's head show
up later in the center of all this is a
big disney animation section and if you
look real close so you can see a
Fantasia Mickey conducting on top of the
big hat you can see Dumbo also a or
shows up right next to her
and a background you can see Captain
Hook's ship and Big Ben from Peter Pan
and of course there's Pixar studios it
has the giant desk lamp and look so ball
there's Toy Story cloud wallpaper Eve
from wall-e there's a good dinosaur
remember that and over on the far left
you can see the balloon house from up
Buzz Lightyear's shows up beside baymax
for big hero 6 and of course all the
Disney Princesses appear as celebrities
though we'll talk more about them in a
bit now we see one girl's avatar take a
Disney Princess BFF quiz and in real
life she looks a lot like Riley from
inside out no I'm not sure that's her I
think her eyes are different we also see
a Q&A with baby Groot with Vin Diesel
actually cameo Lena's voice I like how
he sit in front of a giant guardians of
the galaxy mixtape so here's what my
favorite details there's this
know-it-all fan who asks in this really
nerdy question about Captain America and
red skull this guy is voiced by comedian
Jason Mantzoukas and if the credits he's
listed as the hey Hong man it's actually
a reference to Mantzoukas his character
bit in comedy bang bang hang on man hang
on man hey young man young man new
t-shirt hey young man young man you know
that's a classic hey young man
so vanellope gets chased by some
stormtroopers if you listen closer to
their voices one of them is voiced by
Pixar and rogue one composer Michael
Giacchino and during this case they pass
by a bunch of other little Easter eggs
you can see the wars hammer in a display
case in the background there's a Darth
Vader statue and a backdrop perm The
Nightmare Before Christmas she bumps
the Iron Man and r2d2 again you can also
see Rocket Raccoon and Judy Hopps and
nick wilde from Zootopia and of course a
very quick cameo from the recently
departed Stan Lee which got a very
affectionate and very deserved aah from
the audience I saw it with when she runs
into the craft service area there's a
cameo from the dwarf grumpy that rooster
from Alana Tinker Bell and Peter Pan
shadow and vanellope tries to hide in
the Seven Dwarves dressing-room and he
can hear the music of the Imperial March
from Star Wars and in the background you
see on the wall it says Sector a113
which is a code that shows up and nearly
everything that's animated it's a nod to
the legendary classroom number at
CalArts where a lot of these animators
studied but now if he passes another
door with an Avengers a on it
but instead of going in there bummer she
said glitches into the quarters of the
Disney Princesses now this room is
filled with Disney Easter eggs
the production crew even brought back
the lead animator from those early
nineties Disney films to make sure all
the details were just right
and a lot of the actors returned to
voice the characters I'm gonna run
through all of the details and inside
jokes that he might have missed in each
of these characters first thanks to our
friends from bomb fell for sponsoring
this video look guys I'm a nerd I hate
shopping for clothes I think we all do
but we still want to look good for that
one party a year we get invited to who
try to get invited to a couple more
bombelli is perfect for people like us
you start by filling out a survey of
your body type and your style
preferences and then you will be
assigned a personal stylist who hand
picks clothes or you they'll send you a
bunch of options and you get 48 hours to
decide if you like your stylist choices
you can make any changes you need to
make and once you pick the choices that
you'd like those are mailed to you I
receive my shipment including this comfy
blue shirt casual jeans it's awesome
jacket
turns out fellas jackets are the key to
everything Star Wars was telling us all
along I'm packing this stuff and trying
it on it just felt like I was being
taken care of one less thing to worry
about kind of like an older brother just
handing you something and telling you
and just wear this you'll look good so
once you get your shipment you have 7
days to decide which choices to keep in
which you want to send back but here's
the thing the more stuff that you keep
the more you save like if you keep 4
items you get 20% off cool right you get
close when you want you can pods or
cancel at any time it's completely
flexible and you can sign up on behalf
of a partner too it's a great gift idea
and we worked with palm fell and got
them to give you a
special offer exclusive just for you
guys $25 off your first purchase
just visit banfield.com slash new rock
stars that's boem be fel Elcom slash new
rock stars Lam fell open in clothes ok
back to all the hidden jokes with the
Disney Princesses first there's
Cinderella her vanity has a pumpkin in a
clock stock on midnight above it there's
a cress with the shape of her slipper
and she actually smashes that glass
zipper kind of like a beer bottle in a
bar fight later we see her with all of
her mice in her birds who also helped
make all the clothes for all of them
in when they change clothes she size so
this is love it's referencing the song
from her movie so this is love and if
you look at her new shirt it says g2g
and a carriage silhouette as I've got to
go
then there's snow-white her vanity has a
crest with a poison apple shape which
later appears as a graphic on her new
shirt then there's Sleeping Beauty
Aurora who has initially seen napping
with the rose when Penelope arrives just
like she does in her movie the weapon
that she uses is a spinning wheel
spindle just like the one she pricked
her finger on and then later her new
shirt says nap Queen and she keeps
nodding off okay then on to the next
generation of princesses Ariel from The
Little Mermaid her vanity has a box of
thingamabobs and the candelabra both of
which are from her underground grotto
and above all this the crest on this
area is that shell necklace that Ursula
locked her Voisin later she points the
dinglehopper fork at vanellope and later
if you look at her new design shirt it
says gizmos and whosits and snarfblatt
and dingle hoppers and that new design
layout that people had on their shirts
then there's Belle from Mutina Beast
she's seen with her nose stuck in a book
as she always says and then there's even
more library books on her vanity along
with the enchanted mirror and a
candelabra that looks a lot like Lumiere
later her new clothes feature a graphic
of the beasts head and it says BFF for
beasts friends forever
then there's Jasmine from Aladdin we see
her with Aladdin's carpet in the genie
lamp her Tiger Raja also shows up leader
her shirt is a graphic of the genies
hand holding up three fingers with
wishes written underneath you can also
see Pokemon us now Cinderella is combing
her hair and if you look closely guess
you're pulling the leaf out of it
referencing the leaves that blew through
Pocahontas is hair and colors of the
wind
Pocahontas his weapon is actually her
father's club that he tried to kill John
Smith with and a raccoon Miko shows up
and
later her shirt is a graphic of a wolf
howling up at what else a blue corn moon
next is Mulan who does her cool sword
pose from the movie she also jokes about
reflection just like her famous song and
she mentions how her body of water was a
horse trough later she wears an awesome
track suit jacket with what looks like a
moo shu dragon stitching on it then
there's Tiana from the Frog Prince her
vanity as a picture of Tiana's plays the
restaurant that she dreamed of opening
with her father it also has a plate of
beignets and a photograph of her with
her parents and above it her crest is a
water lily her weapon is a rolling pin
because she loves baking and later her
shirt is a stylized New Orleans NOLA
with the Frog crown logo in the oh
there's also Rapunzel from tangled who
you can see painting inside of her area
cuz Sheila's painting on her vanity
paint boxes her chameleon Pascal and
above that area could see that her quest
is her magical golden flower
I like how she sits on a chair of her
own hair and her weapon is her frying
pan as we mention before later her shirt
says we got a dream from the snuggly
duckling bar house and her leggings
actually have a Sun crest symbol of her
kingdom Merida from brave shows up we
can stand upward she's seen her vanity
has three bears for her brothers and
later her shirt shows a bear wearing a
crown with mum underneath that's for
reference how her mom and her brothers
turn into bears in that movie of course
Anna and Elsa from frozen appear their
vanities at the arendelle royal crest on
Anna's vanity there's sunflowers and the
dolls of her and her sister that she
played with and do you want to build a
snowman
their weapons are throwing hands like
Elsa has her ice powers that come out of
her hands
Anna forms fists referencing how she
punched Hans at the end of that movie
and later on a shirt is finished each
others inside of a sandwich from that
line and love is an open door and Elsa
shirt is just let it go it finally Moana
her weapon is her own or and later her
shirt says hashtag shiny with the giant
crab Tama Toa that was the character who
sang the song shiny in Moana I like how
in the middle of the clothing transition
there's a 60s Batman style transition no
no no a man with a Cinderella Castle and
of course c-3po interrupts their hangout
now moving on one of the interesting
things about Ralph breaks the internet
is the way that the story defies
traditional movie structure like notice
now there's no true villain all the
threats are introduced internally
between the characters in their
relationship the initial quest of
acquiring the sugar rush steering wheel
is actually solved prettier
and then 2/3 of the way through the
movie vanellope gets an i Blount song
and traditionally movies the characters
I one song happens very early so
impressively Ralph rates the Internet
kind of finishes one story and then
gives us a second story after that and
with vanellope slaughter race I want
song there are two details that I really
loved both recounting that shark
license-plate detail I love that detail
but first
early on the song you can see a dancer
in white on the sidewalk his moves are
actually mirroring Michael Jackson's
choreography from the Billie Jean music
video and he's wearing white just like
Michael Jackson dozen that album cover
and the song ends with vanellope and the
slaughter race background characters on
a crumbled highway overpass and there
dancing our car hoods they have their
arms up this seems like a nod to the
choreography of the opening number of
la-la-land ok jumping ahead to later
after Ralph Rex slaughter race and
pisses off an LP we get a few more fun
internet Easter eggs and the abandoned
rebel like you can see the ancient
defunct websites like geo cities AOL the
Netscape Navigator wheel in the
AltaVista logo and the way background
there's like a dial-up train line and
then after Ralph is able to save the
internet from his virus created copies
during this fall the Disney Princesses
return to save him and if you listen
closely to the music this is all a
medley of the classic princess themes
from pretty much all of their movies
it's reflecting how each of them uses
their own unique ways to work together
to rescue Ralph in case you were
wondering that hilarious pancake
milkshake scene from the trailer was
actually added to the end credits that
kind of make a joke out of it the little
girl in that looks almost exactly like
baby Moana apparently this character is
named moe
so that was intentional and there's also
a post post credit scene a sneak peek at
frozen to that ends up being a rick roll
prank it's funny I just liked it better
when Westworld did it you know here's
what I want to know which wreck-it Ralph
movie did you enjoy more Ralph breaks
the Internet or the first movie let me
know comment down below with your
thoughts and follow new rock stars on
twitter and instagram at new rockstars
and for all my deeper weird inner
thoughts you can follow me on twitter
and instagram @ ee vos subscribe to this
channel for more breakdowns of all the
stuff that you missed from your favorite
animations we've done Pixar movies the
lego movie you know Thanos and
lightsabers are technically animated /
computer generator - I guess
everything's a cartoon everything is
also oh that's a different studio